Government is now saying that there are
military programs that are abducting
people and putting them in cages and
breeding them with aliens. You heard
that right. I didn't stutter. This is
real deal. This is mainstream media
news. When I say this is real deal, I'm
not saying that I believe this stuff.
This is what they are propagating to the
public. This is what they want you to
believe. Remember that the mainstream
media is controlled. So, anything that
comes out in mainstream media is because
this is what they want you to believe or
this is the information that they want
you to have. This is the mainstream
narrative. Check this out. Listen to
this video clip. Had someone come and
brief me who was in a military uniform,
worked for the United States Army, that
was briefing me on the locations of
hybrid breeding programs where captured
aliens were breeding with humans to
create some hybrid race that that could
engage in intergalactic communication.
Whoa. Gates added that humans who were
involved were allegedly abducted. So,
they're saying that they're abducting
um
illegal immigrants.
If I If I remember correctly. Let me Let
me let her talk for a second. From war
zones. He said, quote, "What they
explained is that the military ran a
very secret program where aliens that
were living were enforced breeding
programs with humans that had been
abducted from war zones from even the
Caribbean [music] and of migrants."
Gates all So, why is Why is all this
stuff coming out right now? Why are
things coming out to where they're
saying, "Look, aliens are real and the
public
deserves the answers."
Why is 2026 like the year when Epstein
files are coming out? Trump says he's
going to disclose aliens. There are
meteors
almost every day in March
and World War III is going to bring in
Armageddon and Jesus return. Those
aren't my words. That's the words of
people in the military.
Why is all this happening right now and
what is this all about when they're
saying that
there are milit- secret military
programs that are breeding humans with
aliens. If you watch this channel, if
you know my perspective on this
according to the Bible, these aliens are
not aliens. They're demons in disguise
that are going to deceive humanity on a
worldwide scale. They're going to come
in the name of peace and safety and
they're going to take care of some
things. They're going to, you know, fix
climate change and get rid of pandemics
and be doing lying signs and wonders and
miracles, Revelation says, and that the
whole world will be deceived by means of
those miracles. Psychological warfare is
not always what you expect it to be.
It's like reverse psychology.